voici qu'à des eaux
mesdames messieurs c'est le bon retour
de kaleo ce soir à tout le monde en
parle c'est la maison à bâle et à la
maison ici longtemps
bah oui à échanger des plantes et bomba
la boum boum badaboum
ce soir je te le dis car tout de suite
ça perd donc il a pas baiser c'est sa
fête ce soir je compte sur vous vous
trouvez jamal bien kadéos leur tour et
donc on vous voyait plus dans tout le
monde en parle
vous avez quitté comédie en juin dernier
et oui vous n'êtes plus non plus sur
europe 2 et ouais bon vous annoncer sur
canal+ à la rentrée eh oui rien à y
redire ma cachent les hypothèses les
plus folles ont été imaginés une affaire
de moeurs
on a pensé un moment que j'étais parti à
kaboul avec les talibans on a dit que
j'étais proche de l'abbé cottard
ça c'est vrai votre disparition n'est
pas sans rappeler celle de l'un des deux
frères ennemis ou 16 alain devaquet et
puis un jour la production soit une
cassette haye qui s'appelle la grosse
casse est non oui tout simplement la
grosse canon cruchot oui et deux jours
après on reçoit un dvd qui s'appelle
tout simplement le gros dvd oui et la
grâce à dominique farrugia
nous avons pu remonter la piste jusqu'à
vous